hallo mein name ist rica und herzlich
willkommen zu meiner letzten wahl wo
folge ich scheine gerade auf dem server
und zwar wollte ich mich in der online-
oder nein das sind mops da sind muss es
sieht auf jeden fall schon mal nicht gut
aus ich lauf zu den koordinaten 000 weil
da in der nähe ist irgendwo expert.de
gleich eins aufs maul und dann werde ich
mich dort mit den treffen
ich konnte gar nicht richtig essen ist
es scheißegal
da wollte ich mit ihnen treffen so dass
ich gegen die kämpfen kann ich weiß
nicht ob ich gerade in die richtige
richtung laufen ehe das ist nicht
richtig
da sieht es richtig aus und da genau und
ungefähr bei den koordinaten 00 wollte
ich mich mit minecraft expert.de treppen
und gegen ihn kämpfen stähli ist ja wenn
ihr die folge sie schon tot
er geht allerdings beim team auch mit
kommentieren und noch mal ganz kurz
gesagt freunde er ihr euch fragt wieso
geht jetzt in die mitte was soll der
scheiß und so was alles ich mache das
ganze weil ich in den urlaub fahre und
das nicht nur für drei tage sondern für
zwei wochen
und da wollte ich weil ein friseur
findet ihr das sehr kurz sagte hallo zur
minimal wahrscheinlich ein kämpfen
fordert das team das man sonst nie bloss
noch zwei andere auf dem server was die
zockt und skate wie nehme ich mit wenn
ich jetzt gegen tim keine fehler mache
keinen unterschied jetzt mehr viel
weniger oder oder mehr oder whatever nie
mehr ein kilo mehr
egal welches schon welchen von einer
spinne dahinten verfolgen jetzt auf
jeden fall schon selbst egal
ja mir wurde in die kommentare
geschrieben ich kann hier auch mir so
laimer und so soll ich doch am besten
mal machen damit ich hier schon mal ganz
gut die fackel brauch ich denke ich
nicht im kampf damit ich hier schon mal
ein bisschen ausgerüstet bin jetzt so
müsste das ein design und mir wurde das
hier geschrieben das soll dann zu sein
ich kann und jetzt wenn das jetzt stirbt
dann habe ich direkt guckt links von dem
das auf jeden fall ganz geil
also ich fahre in den urlaub allerdings
nicht für drei tage sondern für zwei
wochen
das heißt man darf in war ja nur drei
folgen höchstens vor produzieren
ich meine es ist ja auch richtig so ich
möchte mich auch überhaupt nichts gegen
das regelwerk beschwert ich finde sie
auch eine komplett korrekte regelung
weil natürlich sonst keine spannung drin
wäre das wäre sonst sehr sehr scheiße
und dann wird die witze auch überhaupt
nicht abgehen projekt
laufe ich gerade richtig
sie sind doch nicht ja wahrscheinlich
mit rüstung kommen geht euch doch bitte
vergraben einfach okay okay sind uns
einig ja ich müsste eigentlich richtig
laufen
ich weiß gerade nicht wieder hält nissen
skelett mit einem verzauberten bogen
wahrscheinlich freunde
ich mache mir mal eben im boot glaub ich
kann schnell so schnell ein brot machen
ich muss halt echt durchziehen weil wir
tatsächlich nicht so viel zeit haben und
zu treffen fällt mir dazu auf es auch
wieder so richtig typisch luca erst mal
bot machen jetzt erstmal wieder zehn
jahre in dem städtchen da sitzt es auch
vom karlsruher geil luca hat ja richtig
gelohnt mensch tier das boot zu machen
ist eine richtige richtig ist mehr hier
mensch ich vollidiot lkw fahren hinter
mal schön oben schauen uns dass wir
schon an
also ich bin länger im urlaub deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ja bevor ich jetzt
irgendwie einfach sage ciao freundlich
bin nicht mehr bei wago dabei möchte ich
wenigstens noch mal einmal richtig
kämpfen und gegen wen geht es besser als
gegen den könig schlechthin
der meister des pvp es dass der das
deutsche supertalent in minecraft ist
kaputt gegangen
das war mal wieder klar in den höchsten
tönen von ihm geschwärmt ich kämpfe
gegen tim schwachen in die hose ja das
wollte ich euch sagen so ja ich bin ein
bisschen mehr die mittel sind noch bis
dahin ist denke ich schon die fläche von
uns treffen wollten
die ist sicher bei den koordinaten ein
bisschen auf meine apple was mir das
aufstehen soll werde jetzt hallo creeper
hallo alles gut ich es mal ganz kurz ihr
was
sich aber bitte in ruhe dankbar da
geht's dahin ist jetzt wo die fläche und
dann wird erst mal schön gekämpft gegen
den tipp so schon den ganzen sache nicht
auf dem schlüssel bringen
so und jetzt willst du da nämlich gleich
irgendwo sein
also ich möchte halt einfach jetzt nicht
außen projektarbeit 18
ein screenshot gemacht hieß es ich bin
nervös wie ein kleiner fuchs in natur
für stoße ich sehe da hinten glaub ich
sogar schon seinen namen also gleich
müsste auch ich muss jetzt natürlich
wieder bevor die ganzen leute ankommt so
generiert gar keine spannung kraftlos
achso apropos wenn es ein pvp kampf ist
muss ich natürlich erst mal everyone's
gibt aus es geht los
mutter denn die mir da wo bist du also
hier wollten wir uns definitiv treffen
ich bin schon acht spannende ich mich
richtig angespannt
dieser kampf wird ja nur ausgehen ich
bin so
ich bin richtig angespannt im dow mit
da kommt dem wunsch
er sieht mich jetzt schon schön 1
kämpfen die ganzen zombies er denkt
jetzt bestimmt auch erstmal soll h
dahinter sowie ein schwert aufgesammelt
freunde der endkampf beginnt gegen tim
frist ja alles klar bei dir da hab ich
dann ja auch zwei teile
ich mache hier ist es los aber er weiß
nicht es ist verzaubert
nimm das direct nur becker direktor
heinz schild dennoch geld ich habe auch
gesehen dass sie extra 3 move so einen
scheiß ich glaube es hat noch nie jemand
sein mikro gegen den bildschirm gestarrt
würde mich noch freunde der nacht weil
es eine ein starker kampf wollen und
jetzt bitte nicht hier der super
absichtlich schlecht ich kann es nicht
ich bin nicht gut der hat auch glaube
ich ein verzaubertes schwert an dieser
stelle ge antriebe mir jetzt gar nicht
dann beschweren ich meine ich habe mir
extra dem rausgesucht welt in einer der
am besten ägypten und am besten skills
die spieler im kompletten projekt war
nach mir deswegen mit dem menschenrechte
achtet er könnte mir ein bisschen da
noch zu recht werden
es lag an cache pro ich hatte einfach
die sichtweite zu krass gestellt das war
der grund wer freunde keine ahnung ich
weiß der ein oder andere spieler der
ausgeschieden ist hat so ein so riesiges
ich bin raus ich mein mir egal das ist
ein projekt das kommt einem halben jahr
wieder ich hoffe es hat euch bei mir
gefallen denke ich doch mal sonst schaut
auf jeden fall bei tim vorbei
die er mich getötet hat und schaut auch
bei hallodri weiter wenn ihr sehen wollt
wie es mit dem team erste folge tod
weitergeht wer hat jetzt natürlich nicht
am kampf teilgenommen weil er noch
weiter aufnehmen wollte warum
und dann würde ich sagen hat euch
gefallen
das projekt streits in die kommentare
schreiben die kommentare was eure das
was die pfanne was die witzigste
situation war von dem ganzen projekt
bisher bei mir
mit einblendung oder irgendwie was oder
wo ich runtergefallen oder karouia
schreiben kommentare ich will jetzt
keine lange rede noch halten
mir ist heiß deswegen habe ich weiß bin
einer von euch lecken
denn das gibt bei mir flecken